A full-fashion decrease is a technique
where we manipulate stitches, so
the decreases form a decorative element.
In this video, we'll explore single,fine-tuning
double and triple decreases.
Please watch to the end where we'll give
a tip for fine-tuning this technique.
to work a single full-fashioned decrease,
we transfer one stitch, emptying a needle,
putting two stitches on one needle,
and then we transfer the edge stitches
in to fill the empty needle,
reducing the number of stitches
in work by one, a single decrease.
The extra steps create
this decorative element.
The decreases can be worked,
any number of stitches from the edge.
Here, we've decreased one stitch,
three stitches in from the edge.
Multiple stitches can be decreased
the same way with the same
decorative full-fashioned effect.
For a double decrease transfer
and double up 2 stitches.
There are now two empty needles.
Then transfer the edge stitches in to fill
those empty needles
and two stitches are decreased.
A triple decrease is worked the same way.
But transferring 3 stitches is really
stretching it, so it's best to work
a triple decrease in steps.
First, take off three of the stitches
on a three-pronged tool
and rotate the tool to get those
stitches and the tool out of the way.
Next, using whatever method works best
for you, transfer those edge stitches in.
Filling those empty needles.
In this example, I'm leaving
a 4 stitch edge. Again,
transferring those stitches across
3 needles is way too much.
So I'll just transfer a few at a time
preventing any stretching
or drop stitches.
Once all of the empty needles are filled
in, I'll rehang those held
stitches doubling up.
And I've decreased 3 stitches.
If you're lucky enough to have
a multi-pronged transfer tool,
it can make transferring those
stitches go more quickly.
Here are the results,
we've decreased multiple stitches
and created a nice decorative feature.
This technique is especially helpful when
knitting a European shoulder sweater.
This design moves the shoulders shaping
to the back of the sweater,
and the shaping becomes
an integral part of the design1
As you start manipulating the stitches
for double and triple decreases.
You'll notice that we're stretching
and distorting those stitches.
Right off the machine
You can see my wonky stitches.
plus the edge of the sample is a bit tight.
This is just because of how
we moved the stitches around.
I found that if I manually massage those
stitches a bit and worked any slack over
to the edge stitch,
it not only cleaned up those stretched
wonky stitches, but it
loosened up the edge as well.
Another tip is to alternate your decreases.
if your pattern is telling you to decrease
three stitches four times and two stitches
three times, alternate the double
and triple decreases for a better result.
Please give this technique a try
on a swatch and try this little tip
for perfection and you'll be ready when
you need to do double and triple
decreases in your knitting.